[Musique]
emmanuel macron a annoncé hier qu'un
référendum serait organisé pour intégrer
la défense du climat et la préservation
de l'environnement dans la constitution
ça veut dire que tous les actes qui
seront pris que ce soit les doigts mais
également que toutes les aides de la vie
quotidienne devront respecter ce droit
fondamental à la protection de
l'environnement
constitutionnellement elle doit d'abord
passer par l'assemblée nationale puis le
sénat et être voté dans des termes
identiques
ce jour là elle sera soumise à
référendum ou prend pour qui le jettent
de l'utah pour des veaux des bus vaut
pour des pigeons et lapins de six
semaines
qu'est ce que ça veut dire on n'a pas
d'autres urgences que ça sur cette
annonce de référendum
je tiens à dire que je pourrait la
comparer une éolienne c'est une arnaque
environnementales et politiques ou crois
que c'est beau crois que c'est vert en
fait ça ne pollue la vue et ça nous
polluent l'air il s'agit d'une grossière
manoeuvre de communication à son profit
la défense de l'environnement est déjà
dans une charte qui fait déjà partie le
bloc du bloc de constitutionnalité
et qu'est ce que ça change strictement
rien la preuve
deuxième point c'est qu'il voudrait
qu'on avait vu dire oui précisément au
moment où d'une part il a renoncé à
toute politique d'interdiction dé
glyphosate où il vient de remettre en
route les néonicotinoïdes est un coup
politique construit cours sur une
manuelle et voilà
mais parce que le temps mais encore
faut-il que le scénar vous avez préparé
à jo rites et de droite jouent le jeu
soit c'est un coup politique et je doute
que le sénat y prête la main soit c'est
quelque chose d'utile et il faudra
justement apprécié quelle est l'étendue
notamment des conséquences
simplement je lui fais une proposition
si vraiment il veut lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
et bien qu'ils amènent le ceta devant le
sénat le ceta a été voté par la majorité
en marche à l'assemblée il ya 18 mois
nous l'attendons toujours au sénat parce
qu'on veut le refuser et imaginait
d'ailleurs que les français répondent
non qu'est ce qu'on fait on arrête tout
on sort de là qu'on sort des accords de
paris sur le climat
on se met à ouvrir des centrales à
charbon
ça n'a aucun sens donc la vérité c'est
que il ya là une manoeuvre politique du
président macron celle à qui et où et où
le cynisme tout l'opportunisme d'un
président de la république qui n'a
jamais fait de l'écologie qu'un slogan
qu'une promesse trahie que des
renoncements et maintenant un coup
politique connaît des référendums qui
sont convaincus qu'ils sont par exemple
sur la régionalisation et qui termine
par dès le départ du général de gaulle
donc attention à monsieur mâcon il n'est
pas le général de gaulle mais il peut
terminer de la même façon ça ne doit pas
exonérer évidemment dans la perspective
de la loi climat le gouvernement de
prendre des dispositifs et de mettre des
moyens supplémentaires additionnels pour
les grands objectifs climatiques
la maire de marseille michel rubio la
devrait démissionner près de neuf mois
après son élection à la tête de la
deuxième ville de france
l'écologiste de 64 ans devrait laisser
sa place à son premier adjoint
le socialiste benoît vaillant nous avons
mené campagne ensemble nous avons gagné
ensemble et nous gouvernons ensemble
nous formons un binôme et je souhaite
que notre binôme continue mais s'inverse
effet benoît deviennent mères ça fait
des mois que la rumeur enflait dès
octobre le monde l'annoncé avec cette
petite phrase prononcée par la première
femme maire de marseille tu es au
courant que je reste que trois mois si
vous le pouvez d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
se pratique dans certains pays étrangers
dont beaucoup auto confiné vous huit
jours avant noël si vous pouvez ce n'est
pas possible vous êtes mouillés cette
recommandation bien entendu
est ce que vous avez entendu la tante
embarrassante qui rajoute